[Applause]
such a thrill to have you here uh on the
program
and uh also i i didn't get a chance to
formally thank you you helped me out you
did a bit
on the emmys with me where i locked you
in an airtight container
uh for the uh duration of the show i
think we have a
skill from that yeah
you look legitimately afraid there uh
but it's one of my favorite things that
i i ever got to do and it was because i
got to do it with you
it was it was um you sent me the the
idea and i thought it was a great idea
and um
it was fun plus it's it's television you
know the academy which i'm
you know i'm proud of being part of yeah
yeah it was it was a really fun night i
get it on the street a lot i mean
that's probably usually when i go into a
town people say you sure look like them
right right right and uh but now i get
uh
i voted for you you know uh-huh
i wanted i wanted you to live
so reality show culture now uh now so
much to talk about first of all uh
you know i was so familiar with uh with
the television shows that you did over
the years
loved the shows and before that with
your comedy albums
i didn't know much about what you were
doing before you were stand-up comedian
what what kind of jobs did you have
well i was an accountant i had a degree
in accounting and i worked as an
accountant
and hate it just hated it you hated
being an accountant yeah yeah
very boring and uh wasn't as thrilling
and sexy as you thought it was going to
be
and uh and and so i
i i left accounting i said i've got to
find out
um i've got to take two years out of my
life i was single and there's no
responsibility and so
i said i gotta take two years out of my
life and find out if i can make it in
in comedy otherwise i'll spend the rest
of my life saying i wonder
what would have happened right and at
least i i can say well i tried it and
didn't work so
so i left accounting and i would take
part-time jobs and try to break into
comedy writer you know funny disc jockey
whatever whatever
i never thought it was going to be a
stand up i mean that was furthest thing
from my mind
and i once worked one of the jobs i had
i take these temporary jobs
and i once worked for the the illinois
state unemployment
compensation board i worked behind the
counter at the unemployment office
right and and we got at that time
this was in the 50s we got 65
a week that was your salary 65 a week
and the claimants was 55.
[Laughter]
people coming in yeah and they only had
to come in one day a week right
it took me a few days to figure hey for
10 bucks you know i can i can have
four days off right
so i got fired yeah yeah and then you
came back
in yeah that's right next week now
you've been married uh you mentioned
this you were in your single days you
met you've been married 43 years 43 yeah
yeah
what's the incredible i think
what do you think is the secret of
having a relationship that lasts that
long
well i have a wife who um she keeps me
grounded
she doesn't let me get too full of
myself you know and
if your your wife is the same way oh god
yes yeah yeah
yeah she is yeah she talked me into in
the book about we took a
a recreational vehicle trip
from hell yeah yeah with the kids
because she wanted
so in la we have a on
on wednesdays they pick up the the trash
and
and we have to separate it into uh
recyclable and non-recyclable and so
like on a tuesday late in the afternoon
jenny will say to me
you know you got to take out the
recyclable you know because they're
they're picking it up tomorrow morning
and and i'll say to her what do you
think paul newman
do you think you think joanne woodward
asked paul newman to take out
the recyclables right and she says well
if you were paul newman i wouldn't ask
you to take
keeps you grounded it's very good yeah
you you uh i
grew up watching you uh you were one of
my favorite guests on the tonight show
you're doing the tonight show with
johnny carson
and uh always a thrill to see you on
that show what was it like
uh being on that program as a guest did
you because i know that you and johnny
were
were close so was it yeah we were
friends and um
john when the monologue
didn't go well uh john
kind of he kind of was going down with
the ship and
and he was he was taking everybody on
the show with him you know
right right the guests whoever he if the
monologue didn't go well so
uh i i would i i maybe we made a trip
with the rickles and and i i'd be
pre-interviewed you know and
say right bob has a funny story about he
just got back from a trip with the
rickles and
he has a funny story so i'd come out
and uh and it's right there on the sheet
for the question for the first question
for johnny to ask
and uh johnny would get that look in his
eyes
and he'd say uh yeah you ever went to
india
i can't imagine a meaner thing to do to
a comedian
you've got nothing prepared yet i knew
i'd never been to india yeah and
didn't have a joke about right right and
uh
but what he would do and johnny would he
would do it for all the guests
is he would never let you look bad right
now he would make sure
he i was a stand-up comic he was a
stand-up comic so
he he he kind of trusted that i would i
would somehow handle it you know
and but he would never let you look at
you had such a comfortable relationship
you played a prank on him once i've
heard
i've heard about this uh on the air
while johnny was interviewing a guest
yeah john used to do it used to be an
hour and a half show uh
and usually the half last half hour was
um
was an author of some kind and at the
end of the
the couch there was this uh
clock you know and johnny would look at
it see how much time left and
how much more does he have to do before
he can wrap it up yeah so i did my slug
with him so i moved here and then
we had another guest and then i moved
down and i'm seated next to ed and ed's
right next to the clock
so he brings out this author and he was
a particularly
boring author yeah yeah so
so every time john looked away i told ed
i said move move it back
he would talk to the author i need to
look over at the clock and go
[Applause]
i can only imagine i can imagine what
that would feel like
we have a lot more to talk about we're
gonna take a break more with bob newhart
uh when we return we'll see in a second